here in the beautiful island of Haiti
among the tobacco and cane sugar field
workers honey only and firemen when the
us occupied Haiti for two decades in the
early 20th century it only intensified
Americans fascination with a part of its
religious culture known as voodoo
spiritual beliefs and practices
originating in West Africa where
European colonial powers enslaved
thousands and thousands of people and
brought them to the island in the
previous centuries at fascination like
the occupation had a racist strain a
combination of fear anxiety and
hostility toward the so called black
magic of a primitive culture it was
during this period that this guy William
Seabrook journalist occultist and
generally eccentric minor celebrity
visited Haiti to report on the
occupation but found himself drawn
instead to voodoo resulting in a 1929
book entitled the Magic Island though it
was and is accused of being sensational
and insensitive the book captured the
public's interest and one chapter in
particular has had a lasting impact on
popular culture in dead men working in
the cane field Seabrook effectively
introduces the world to zombies the
zombie they say is the soulless human
corpse still dead but taken from the
grave and endowed by sorcery with a
mechanical semblance of life the zombies
of Haitian folklore are controlled by a
sorcerer called a bokor who uses them
for his own ends often for menial work
resembling the slave labor and by the
way they don't eat or crave human flesh
at this point once in the popular
imagination it took only three years for
this conception of the zombie to find
its way to Hollywood to a film industry
eager for another monster after the
successes of Dracula and Frankenstein
drawing from the Magic Island and a
Broadway play 1932 s white zombie he
came the first zombie movie ever set in
Haiti the story stars Bela Lugosi as a
voodoo sorcerer who helps a plantation
owner turn the object of his desire into
a zombie so that she'll be with him the
terror here is in a white couple being
controlled in the same way as the
Haitians the bigoted subtext is all too
obvious the white zombie wasn't as
successful as Dracula or Frankenstein it
did spawn a number of zombie films along
these lines in the following years and
decades
each follows from the conception that
seabrooke outlined in his book slave
like henchman controlled by a master in
1966 Hammer films
plague of the zombies created undead
that look like the ones we know today
but Haitian voodoo was still the
touchstone but in 1968 everything
changed thanks to this man George Romero
and his skeleton crew of collaborators
who made the zombie film that reinvented
the genre Night of the Living Dead it's
impossible to overstate Romero's impact
every zombie film or comic or TV show
whatever made in the last 50 years is a
direct descendant of this film
Romero changed the rules first and
foremost he dispensed with the master
slave dynamic his undead aren't under
the control of anyone or anything for
some unknown reason maybe scientific
maybe not
they are reanimated as pure instinct
scouring the earth on whatever limbs
they have left seeking one thing the
living killers
[Music]
Romero's zombies devour living human
beings they hobble forward awkwardly but
relentlessly they're dumb able to use
objects as blunt-force instruments but
nothing else they can only be killed by
being shot in the head or burned and if
one bites or scratches you you'll die
not long after then transform into one
and pursue whoever is nearby family or
not if these creatures don't resemble
the zombies of Haitian Vodou that's
because Romero didn't think of his
undead as zombies in night they're
called ghouls and they're derived more
from Richard Matheson's novel I am
Legend then William Seabrook how these
flesh eaters came to be known as zombies
is a bit foggy but by the time Romero
made the sequel Dawn of the Dead he
adopted the name - whether there are
enough similarities to consider the Prix
Romero and post Romero history of
zombies continuous is up for debate what
is clear is that when pretty much anyone
thinks of zombies nowadays they're
thinking of Romero zombies one reason
for this is that these are just creative
primal monsters but another reason I
think why Romero zombies have been so
lasting is because his original trilogy
particularly the first two installments
are really outstanding movies night of
the dead and it's neo-realist black and
white style is a smart tightly crafted
story made on a shoestring budget with a
third act that is an absolutely brutal
and punishing even now fifty years later
in Dawn of the Dead his festival
I think Romero keys in to the symbolic
potential of his monsters in a way that
he was only hinting at in night the film
which takes place almost entirely in a
mall uses zombies to critique
consumerism as the zombies lumber
through this familiar place we see our
own behavior as a grotesque reflection a
zombies thoughtlessness Romero
understood is the perfect mirror for
these days the zombie is everywhere
you've seen the shows played the games
watch the trailers it's more than firmly
established as a horror trope
which means that it'll likely stay with
us for a very long time its history is
complicated a tangle of appropriation
and invention prejudice and creative
genius and awesomeness in other words
it's a modern myth I'm thinking zombies
y-you know zombies ghouls the undead
everybody thank you so much for watching
this episode was brought to you by
Squarespace if you don't know you can
use Squarespace to make beautiful
websites for anything you might need a
personal site a wedding website a site
for your business or portfolio a blog
and in just a few clicks you can have
that website up and running their design
team has crafted templates that work on
computer browsers and on mobile so they
switch perfectly between the two you can
integrate your own photos and videos and
you can even link your social accounts
so that you can Auto post to Twitter and
Facebook all from within Squarespace
head over to Squarespace calm for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com slash nerdwriter
for 10% off your first purchase thanks
again guys I'll see you next time